أنت تقرأ عقول الناس ،
لذلك لا نحب استخدام مصطلح
قراءة العقل لهؤلاء العلماء الجدد في
جامعة تكساس وأوستن يقولون
إنهم حققوا إنجازًا كبيرًا ، حيث
اكتشفوا كيفية ترجمة
نشاط الدماغ إلى كلمات باستخدام
المصطنعة.  الذكاء ، هذه
صور مختلفة في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر ، قاموا
بنشر ورقة تشرح كيف
استمع متطوعون باحثون إلى
مقاطع صوتية أثناء فحص أدمغتهم
بواسطة جهاز fmri بمرور الوقت ، خوارزميات الذكاء الاصطناعي
نفسها التي تقف
وراء الدردشة gbt يمكننا اكتشافها
ما كان يستمع إليه المتطوعون
فقط من خلال مشاهدة أدمغتهم ، من
الجنون أن تشاهد كيف يتدفق الدم
عبر الدماغ وباستخدام Ai و gbt
وكل شيء آخر مترجم إلى
كلمات ، نعم من
العجيب أن هذا يعمل عندما تضعه
بهذه الطريقة Thumbs Up Down  آس
لاختبار كل شيء ، البروفيسور ألكساندر
هووس ، وقمت بفحص دماغنا أثناء
الاستماع إلى أجزاء من كتاب ساحر أوز
الصوتي ، لم يكن لدي سوى دماغ
كبير بشكل بغيض ، حسنًا ، داني
لدينا صورة لدماغك ،
يبدو الأمر جيدًا.  اللطيف أولًا
تبعه البروفيسور خرطوم لالتقاط
صور للتغيرات في
تدفق الدم في دماغنا بينما نستمع إلى الكلمات
من الكتاب الصوتي ونظهر كيف
تفسر أدمغتنا هذه الكلمات عندما
تنتهي من وجبتها وكانت على وشك العودة
إلى طريق الأصفر  لقد
شعرت بالدهشة لسماع تأوه عميق بالقرب منك ،
يمكنك أن ترى أنهم يحصلون على
تسجيلات كل ثانيتين بينما يستمع
إلى قصة سنقوم بتغذية هذه
البيانات من خلال وحدة فك التشفير الخاصة بنا ومحاولة
التنبؤ بالقصة التي
يستمع إليها حاليًا في صباح اليوم التالي
كانت النتائج على ما يرام ، لذا فقد مرت 24
ساعة منذ أن أجرينا مسحًا ضوئيًا لدماغنا ،
يمكنك التأكد من أن لدي دماغًا
رائعًا تمامًا ، لذا تمكنا من
فك تشفير بعض الأشياء لعقلي ليس
كثيرًا من عقلك ، لذا أه هذه واحدة من
عقلي هذا  هي من ساحر أوز ،
لذا على الجانب الأيسر هي الكلمات الفعلية
التي سمعتها عندما أنهت
وجبتها وكانت على وشك العودة إلى
طريق الطوب الأصفر ، فذهلت
لسماعها عميقة نمت في الجوار
والنسخة التي تم فك شفرتها  من هذا على
اليمين ، لقد كنت على وشك العودة
إلى المدرسة وسمعت هذا الصوت الغريب
يناديني لذا فهمت بعض الأشياء
بشكل صحيح ، لذا كان هذا مثل كان على وشك العودة
كان على وشك العودة ، فهو
يفتقد تمامًا لبعض الأشياء مثل  طريق
الطوب الأصفر مقابل المدرسة ولكن بعد ذلك
تحصل على هذا النوع الجميل من الأمثلة
لذلك تسمع شيئًا ثم بدلاً
من تأوه عميق قريب ، كان لها
صوت غريب يناديني فهذا يعني
شيئًا مرتبطًا حتى لو لم يكن
صحيحًا تمامًا  لا تزال الكلمات
لا تصدق إلى حد كبير للاعتقاد بأنها كانت على وشك
العودة كشيء بمجرد
مسح دماغك ، أعتقد أن هذا
أحد الأشياء التي
تثير دهشتنا حقًا بشأن هذا الأمر ، حيث يمكنه الحصول على
أشياء مثل أنه يمكنه الحصول على هذه
العبارات الكاملة للكلمات الدقيقة  حسنًا ، هذا هو
نفس المقطع بالنسبة لك الآن ، لذا
توقعنا ألا أكون غريس لأننا
لم ندرب النموذج عليك
طوال اليوم ، سأكون بخير لكنها أرادت أن
أصل إلى مكانها أولاً ، لقد حصلت على
القليل  متحمسًا لذلك
السبب في عدم تمكنه من فك شفرة
دماغي هو أن التكنولوجيا
تحتاج حاليًا إلى أن يجلس الناس في
آلة fmri لأكثر من 16 ساعة حتى
تتمكن نماذج الذكاء الاصطناعي من التدريب على أدمغة
أشخاص محددين ، فهل سنعيش في
عالم حيث  أنت تعلم أنه يمكنني السير بجانب
شخص ما في الشارع وسيكونون
قادرين على حمل شيء ما في رأسي
وسيعرفون ما أفكر فيه حاليًا
أننا بعيدون جدًا عن أنه قد
لا يكون ممكنًا أبدًا.  ر
استبعاد ذلك تمامًا ولكن بقدر ما نعلم أنه
بالتأكيد لن يكون ممكنًا في
العقود القليلة القادمة ، فإن التطبيق المحتمل الحقيقي
لهذا هو في الواقع مساعدة
الأشخاص غير القادرين على التحدث دون
الحاجة إلى
إجراء جراحة الأعصاب الآن لدينا هذا مثل
لقطة  من الدماغ وشرح جيري تشانغ
كيف استخدموا
نموذج لغة GPT الكبير المفتوح لمنظمة العفو الدولية للمساعدة في فك تشفير الدماغ ،
يتكون نموذج GPT من
ملايين الصفحات من النص من
الإنترنت التي يتدرب عليها الذكاء الاصطناعي
ويتعلم كيفية بناء الجمل
وكيف يتم بناء الناس.  التحدث والتفكير جعل gbt أساسًا
تنبؤاتنا أفضل كثيرًا ولكن الأمر
لا يقتصر على الاستماع إلى
أستاذ الصوت الذي أظهر لنا ما حدث
عندما شاهد فيلمًا بدون صوت
أثناء فحص دماغه ، شاهد حيث أن
التكنولوجيا قادرة على فك شفرة ما
عيناها ترى ، ثم أمسكت بيدي
وأمسكت بها على شفتيها قبلتها ،
ابتسمت يا إلهي أنا
أعانقها لساعات ، كان علي أن
أوقف النزيف وأعطيتها قميصي
لأرتديه
كان  جيد جدًا ، لا أعلم أنه ليس
وصفًا لما كان يحدث هنا ،
يا للروعة إذا كنا خائفين من العمل الذي
كان يقوم به الأشخاص مثلك ، نعتقد أنه من
المهم حقًا التقييم المستمر
للآثار المترتبة على فك تشفير الدماغ
وكذلك البدء في التفكير في سن
السياسات  التي تحمي الخصوصية العقلية
وتنظم ما يمكن استخدام بيانات الدماغ من أجله